Hi, in the previous lecture I talked about
the rational actor model. In the rational
actor model individuals had objective
functions and they made optimal choices,
made optimal decisions given those
objectives. In this lecture I want to talk
about something called behavioral models.
Now behavioral models are critical of the
rational actor assumption and they're
critical for two reasons. One is, there's
a lot of observations, there's a lot of
data, from experiments in the laboratory
and from just looking at the real world,
that people seem to systematically deviate
from optimal choices. It's also the case
as we sort of understand how the brain
works, the more deeply, that there's
evidence from neurology that, just the way
our brain is structured, the way we encode
and represent information, the way we
think, causes us to systematically differ
from what the rational actor model would
assume. So what I'm going to do in this
lecture is I obviously can't give a full
accounting of the behavioral revolution
within economics or of all of psychology.
So what I'm going to do is just hit some
high points. I'm going to talk about four
well-documented biases and talk about
their implications for when we think about
modeling people. Before I get there
though, I just want to give a little bit
of background. So Daniel Kahneman is a
psychologist and he won a Nobel Prize
actually in economics for his work on how
people systematically differ from the
rationality assumption. So he's got a
recent book out called Thinking Fast and
Slow. And in this book he makes the
following point. You can think of the
brain as having two sorts of processes. A
slower process that's a little bit closer
to rational that processes information,
and then fast processes that are more
likely to work based on emotion or just
based on quick clues. So as a result,
these fast processes may make us biased,
right, in ways that the rational actor
model assumes that we're not, right? The
rational argument assumes that we sort of
think slowly and carefully about
everything. But Kahneman argues that we
think both fast and slow and as a result
we make some mistakes. Now there's another
book by Cass Sustien and Richard
Thaler who then would argue that
these biases have real implications for
policy. And that's one of the things we're
going to talk about. It's one thing to say
people make mistakes. Remember in the last
lecture I said, well some people make
mistakes high and some people make
mistakes low, those are just going to
cancel out and there's nothing we can
really do about it. What they argue is
that these mistakes, because they're
systematic had implications for how we
construct policy. And we'll talk about
that as well. Okay, so what are we going
to do? Well, we're going to do four
examples. We're going to take four
particular types of biases that are
well-documented. The first one is
something called 'prospect theory' and
this is the idea that we look at gains and
losses a little bit differently. Second
one is something called 'hyperbolic
discounting'. This deals with how much we
discount the future and how that changes
depending on how far in the future it is.
Third, there's something called the status
quo bias. There's a tendency to sorta just
stick to what we're currently doing and
not make changes. And this is one that has
big implications for policy. And then the
last one is something called the base rate
bias. And that is that we can just be
influenced by what we're currently
thinking. So what I wanna do is just show
you some examples of each of these. Maybe
talk a little bit about some evidence from
experiments in the real world that, that
you know, suggest that these things really
are biases. And then I'll be a little bit
critical about this whole approach at the
end and sort of push back a little bit.
Okay? Alright. Let's get started. So
prospect theory. Suppose I say to you,
okay, you've got two options. Option A is
I can give you 400 bucks for sure. Here's
$400 right now. Option B, 50 percent of
the time I'll give you $1,000, I'll flip a
coin. Comes up heads, you get 1,000 bucks,
but 50 percent of the time when I flip the
coin I get a tails, I'll give you nothing.
So you go to decide, 400 bucks for sure,
or this 50-50 proposition. So if you give
this to people, a lot of people choose
"A". A lot of people say "look, I'll take
the 400 bucks." Now suppose I ramp this
up. Suppose I said $400,000,000.00 for
sure, for a 50/50 chance at,
$1,000,000,000.00 or nothing. And almost
everyone would choose A. Right? So, as
amounts get larger, people tend to be what
we call risk adverse. In gains. But,
here's what Kahneman showed. This is what
prospect theory is. Suppose it's a loss.
Suppose I say okay. Option A. Is I'm just
going to take $400.00 from you. Or, we can
flip a coin and half the time I'll take
$1000 from you which is even more, and
half the time I'll take nothing. Well it
turns out, people are actually more likely
to choose B in this setting because we're
risk loving over losses. So the
risk averse over gain and risk loving over
losses, and that's different than what
you'd get from a rational actor
assumption. So this is just a systematic
deviation, and this explains why people
take gambles maybe that they shouldn't
take. Okay, that's one. Let's go to the
next one. Hyperbolic discounting. Suppose I
say to you, here's option A. I'll give you
1,000 bucks right now, or wait until
tomorrow, and I'll give you 1,005 dollars.
What do you take? Well, a lot of people
are gonna say you know what? Just give me
the 1,000 bucks today. Most people say,
I'd rather get the $1,000 right now than
wait a day to just get five dollars more. Now.
Suppose I say to you okay. Here's option
A. I'll give you $1,000.00 a year from
today, or I'll give you $1,005.00 a year
and a day from today. Well, here most
people say, well look. We're waiting a
year anyway. What's one more day? I'll
take option "B". Well if you write down a
rational actor model where I'm trying
to maximize wealth and I've got some
discount rate or something like that, if I
in this case choose A then in this case I
should also choose A, but most people
don't do that and the reason why is we
discount the near future. >> Right? A lot
more than we discount that same amount of
time in the far future. So this is called
hyperbolic discounting, where immediate
gratification matters a lot to us
and so therefore we discount
short periods of time from right now a lot
more than we do short periods of time down
the road. So this has implications and
it has what is called sort of the "chocolate
cake" implication. So suppose I say, you
know, I want to be fit. I want to stay in
great shape, I want to be healthy. And so
someone said to me, "okay, you know... " A
week from now, would you want to have
chocolate cake with your desert or not.
You know for desert or not. Would, would
you forgo the chocolate cake. I'll say
absolutely, I'm going to forgo the
chocolate cake because the thing is, I
really want to get in shape. But the thing
is if I'm sitting at dinner and someone
put the chocolate cake in front of me Even
though I want to lose weight. Even though
like I really want to be fit. The
chocolate cake's right there. I can't put
it off. Because there's just, there's,
let's see, it's, it's just right there in
front of me and so if you say in
Kahneman's language, I am thinking fast,
right. I don't have a long drawn up
thinking that allows me to make the
rational choice and so what's gonna happen
is I am gonna choose the cake now and make
what would be a sub optimal choice. Third
something called the status quo bias. So
suppose you got the phone, you go to work
and it says, check this box, you can just
check to contribute to the pension fund or
not. And so I'm sitting there thinking
"well, you know if I check here that means
its going to take money out of my, You
know, salary out of my paychecks here, I'm
not gonna check it. Now, alternatively,
what my firm could do is it could say,
well, check box to not contribute to the
pension fund, so this is called a negative
check off. So if I check here, then they
won't contribute. Otherwise, they will.
Well, what happens here is, again, I
think. From a status quo standpoint, oh I'm
already contributing. No, I don't want to
pull that money out. So it sort of seems a
little like the prospect theory thing,
right? So what happens here is most
people, in this case, wont check the box.
Right, most people won't check up here,
and most people won't check down there.
Now how do we know this? We know this by
looking at organ donations. So in England,
if you want to donate an organ, it says,
they say this, check this box to donate
the organ. And you know how many people
check the box? 25%. If you look to the
rest of Europe, there's a little thing
that says, checkbox, to not donate your
organ. And you know how many people check
the box? Ten%. So in the countries in
Europe in which you have to check the box
to not donate your organ, 90 percent of
people donate their organs. In England
where you have to check the box donate,
donate, to donate your organs, only 25
percent of people check the box. So,
extremely large status quo bias. And that
again is a deviation from rationality.
Okay, last one. What I want you to do, is
I want you to think of the year, that you
think. This is a box made sometime during
this century, the last century. I'm sorry.
in the 1900's. I want you to guess the year
that this box was made, and I want you to
write it down. Okay. You've got it written
down? Now what I want you to do is I want
you to guess how much this box costs. So I
want you to guess, how much you think this
box is worth, if you were to you know, you
know, buy it on the web. [inaudible]. How
much do you think the box is worth? So
this is a bias called the base rate bias.
Look at the two numbers you wrote down.
The first one is the year you thought it
was, made. So suppose I thought this thing
was made in 1960. Then, I want you to
think, what price did you write down? And
maybe you wrote down 63 dollars, right?
Those two numbers tend to be fairly close.
So what the base rate bias is, if you get
people thinking about one number, and then
you ask them something else, that second
number will tend to be close to the first
number. So what you get, right, is this
bias that makes no sense at all. So you
can do this, you can ask people, like,
think of a phone, think of the last two
digits of someone's phone number, and then
price the box. And what you'll find is
their prices are fairly close to the last
two digits of the phone number. So this
base rate bias is just a clear deviation
from rational behavior, optimal behavior.
Okay, so we've looked at these four
things. Prospect theory, hyperbolic
discounting, status quo bias, base rate
bias. They're all well documented. So
they're all well documented deviations
from rational behavior. So, there's a ton
of these, right? So if you go and look out
in the web you'll see a list of hundreds
of hundreds of biases, right that have
been found in the laboratory. Now there's
people who are critical of this, right?
And so one of the acronyms that I
sometimes hear in the psychology
department is weird. And if they say that
the results are weird. Now, what do they
mean? Weird stands for Western Educated
Industrialized Rich Developed countries.
So most of these biases, even though
there's lots of biases, most of them have been
found on experiments with people like me. Western
rich industrialized people from western
rich industrialized countries. So one of
the things that we're trying to figure
out, is, how many of these biases hold true
across different populations and different
cultures? Some of them do, and some of
them probably won't. Now there's another
issue with these, right, you know there's
lots of these biases. People tend to
learn, and again remember we talked about
if the stakes are large, right, maybe
they'll learn the way out of the box. So,
the Monty Hall problem, are they picking
the door which the prize was? People
suffer from a bias there right, a status quo
bias. They stick to their door, but after
they play it enough it goes away. So one
of the questions is, right, how strong are
these biases through repeated interaction, and do
they go away? Last point about this
behavior [inaudible], when you think about
modeling you may say boy, you know what,
it's right, I think people suffer from
hyperbolic discounting. I think that
there's prospect [inaudible] if there's a
base rate bias. I want to include all
these biases in my model. Computationally
that can be a really difficult thing to
do. So one reason why when you look at
[inaudible], we're going to be using
simple rules or maybe assuming people
optimize even though we know people suffer
from biases. It's that it can just be
computationally hard. It can be difficult,
right, to write down a model where you
include these biases. Nevertheless, the
biases are there. And when you think about
a model of people, we don't necessarily
want to peo, assume the people optimize.
Nor as we look next, we want to see the
people necessarily just follow simple
rules. Instead, we may want to assume that
people are these complicated messy things
with these biases. It's just that can be
sometimes hard to do unless elegant. Okay,
so how do we think about this, how do we
think? Here's I think one way, is that if
I'm running down a model. It may not be a
bad way to start, by sort of assuming
people make optimum choices given some
simple objective function. Then I want to
ask myself. Okay, what biases are out
there? What is the list of documented
biases? Given this list of documented
biases, do I think any of these are going
to come into play? How large do I think
they'd be and how relevant are they for
this particular case? I might also say
boy, maybe I should do some experiments,
right. Maybe I should go look out there in
the world and see are people behaving the
way that my rational actor model seems to be
behaving. And if not, right, if, if
there's reason to believe that one of
these biases is kicking in then I want to
include the bias. But because there's so
many of them, I can't include them all. So
I want to think about which ones of them
are most relevant. So what you see a lot
of times, in models that try to explain
behavior is they'll sort of be, what I
call sort of, rational minus, or rationale
plus. Right? So they're sort of, a little
bit less than rationale behavior, because
what they've done is take rationality, and
added in a bias. And that's one way
to write down useful models of
individuals. Okay, thanks.